hello everyone and welcome to round nine
of the world rabbit championship it's
Alexander Zubov ukrainian grandmaster
versus magnus carlsen and the last year
they played in the world rabbit
championship they faced in Round seven
and Zubov defeated Magnus Carlsen calls
and had the black piece he went for the
nimzo-indian and Zuba was able to take
him down so here is Carlson's check a
chance to get his revenge again with the
black pieces so let's see how the game
went Zuber would the white pieces opens
with d4 we have Knight to f6 by Magnus
Knights to f3 now and d5 we have c4 e6
III and now a 6 so b3 preparing to
fianchetto the dark square bishop and
the Magnus goes for a c5 with Bishop to
b2 I think at doing the dark square
Bishop C capture Sundy for e captures
and the just night day and night to c6
continuing development we have Knight B
to d2 and g6 now Magnus also wants to I
think after his dark square Bishop the
counter White's dark square bishop we
have Bishop to d3 and Bishop to g7 Queen
e2 and here both players just Castle and
Magnus goes b6 he wants the thing
gathered the light square bishop as well
and now there is one game where rook a
to C 1 but here is ooh both goes for
rook a to d1 and it is as of move 12th
that we have a completely new game so
Magnus continues with Bishop to b7 I
think it was the light square Bishop
rook F the e1 and now to Frieda the
light square Bishop D captures on c4
with B captures on c4 strengthening the
center and here are very interesting
move b5 as the a to pawn is unguarded
here you can trade off the points on the
Queen set because after captures
captures and captures there's also
captures so grabbing back in the pond
also with with an attack on the bishop
here so instead after b5 Zubov says okay
I'm just gonna create a passed pawn here
so he pushes c5 with Queen to c7
developing the Queen connecting rooks
and now Knight to e4 we have Knight
captures Bishop characters and the
Magnus says okay let's trade off the
lights partnerships as well Knight to e7
we're shop captures Queen captures and
here dubov goes for not to do both sorry
Zubov goes for d5 point is that if pawn
captures then of course you lose the
night here so and if Bishop captures and
b2 it's playable but there's the D in
between c6 attacking the Queen Queen to
b6 now after the Queen is captured
Knight captures here and mount 95
defending the past C C pawn also there's
the threat of knife 37 so white white
would definitely enjoy this so Magnus
goes for Knight captures on d5 first but
we will reach a very similar position we
have a bishop character son b7g 17
captures we have Queen to be to check by
Zubov King to g8 and now Knight to e5 so
the night the point is ready to be
pushed to c6 with rook F to d8 by Magnus
getting the rook to do only open file on
the board in the now c6 now we have
Queen to c7 blocking the pawn and now H
for preparing h5 Magnus defends it with
h5 and now rook to d4 being ready to if
G for his plate and H captures the
recapture with the rook and to bring the
rook into the attack
Magnus doesn't want to allow this here
Magnus goes for night the b6 he offers
the rook trade and here's a really good
moment in the game this is a very
interesting position and here
Zubov played g4 he wants to bust open
the position and start an attack against
Carlsen scheme but there was a better
move than g4 first Ruby DT for just
avoid the trade avoid Carlsen to
activate the other rook and now after
the rooks are nicely doubled on efile
next move you can play g4 you have ideas
of even sacrificing the night and g6 a
lot of things become possible but he he
rushed the attack a bit too much with
the g4 and he a lot Carlsen to activate
his wealth to get rid of this Rookwood
rook captures on d4 Queen captures and
now he got to the other look into the
game for free with Queen to f4 and now
across and spent some time deciding
whether Knight captures and g6 is a
danger or not and in the end he decided
it's not he just played H captures on g4
and now subo has to decide whether he
wants to recapture with the Queen Knight
captures ng4 is great if Magnus actually
captures it for example Czech Queen
blogs Queen captures an d6 with the
check and you don't want to play this I
mean yeah white already has a past C
pawn you you just grab the three points
for the piece you have a very easy way
of getting your rook into the attack so
the only white can win this game however
the problem is after nightcap percent g6
you don't have to capture the night you
just play something like 95 and now the
white it doesn't have a way to continue
this attack
you bring the knight back f5 is coming
you you defend your g4 pawn and after
the Queen moves Queen to c2 rook the c8
and it's well it's a different game of
course it is playable but after a
chapters on g4 Zubov continues with h5
it is the best way to continue the
attack and Magnus goes for the Counter
Strike in g3 he asks what what do you do
now and the best is the capture on g6
after H captors and g6 you have to go f6
kick away the knight Knight goes back
and now Knight to d5 defending the f6
pawn Queen captures any sex with check
King g7 and now rook the rook to d1 g
captures an F - it's always playable
Knight captures on f2 and again the game
continues but this would have been the
best course of action for Zubov after
cross and g3 maneuver but Zuba was a
very long time here he first captured
the pawn and now he allows crossing this
Knights the c-4 maneuver where if if the
knight is captured then you have this
in-between Queen captures and g3 with
checks so again it's best just to go for
the g6 pawn Knight captures on e5
defending f7 with the night so Queen
captures on e5 here we would have a
queen trade captures captures and after
going after the c6 bond we would see
captures captures and it's a rockin game
where both players have three points
where black is the slight favor due to
the more active King but after Knight to
c4
Zubov captured in the night uncie for
allowing this Queen captures and g3 idea
and okay we have a king to f1 blocking
and now beat captures and c4 subha now
characters and g6 but now it is too late
for such things here Magnus goes
rook to d2 he threatens mate on f2 rook
to d3 was even better as rook to f3 is
somewhat of an unstoppable threat but
okay it doesn't really change all that
much because you can always go back look
to d2 and now we have captures on f7
with check King f8 and the now look the
e2 the only good way to block this and
now rook to d1 check by Magnus we rook
to e1 and the now feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the best move
for black while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations I'm still paying
attention after so many video uploads
and for those you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's rook to d3 and the threat of rook
f3 check that there's nothing you can do
about this it's just too strong however
after this rook to e1 Magnus actually
played rook captures and he won and he
went into a queen and pawn endgame but I
guess this is just what happens when
you're when you're so confident in your
endgame skills with Queen capture sunny
one Queen to f3 check to pick up the c6
pawn queen to f2 and then out just
captures but even though this is a three
against two you've seen if not anywhere
else on this channel that the Queen and
one end games are so complicated and you
know a pawn up is never almost never
enough but okay this nope of Queen to f6
and now comes Queen to e4 Carlsen spawns
are all nicely defended we have pink the
g1 Queens the g4 check King to h2 and
now a5 he starts pushing his pawns
further and here Zuba decides to give up
the f7 pawn for the D a 5-point so Queen
to d8 check King captures and Queen
captures on a5 check we have Quinta e -
width check King to g3 and now Queen III
check we have King to g4 in the now c3
Carlsen continues pushing his passport
Queen to c7 with check King to g6 and
the
Quinta c4 we have Queen to e5 and now
comes a four Zubov starts pushing his
passport as well we have Queen to f5
check King to g3 and now Magnus just
played c2 and it was in this position
that Alexander's who will resign the
game and Magnus was able in getting his
revenge for last year's loss in round 7
point is whatever white plays there are
no checks
well no no useful checks so whatever you
play you move the Queen you play a 5 you
just play Queen g5 check and now the
Queen from g5 guards c1 whatever you
play King f2 now it's just another Queen
into the game and of course the two
queens are always better than one you
know most of the time so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it
with this win and Magnus joins the
leaders there are now four players
leading the tournament with 7 out of 9
Magnus Carlsen Ivanka who already faced
Magnus Carlsen
they drew they drew that London system
game Lagrangian and the Maxime for
Sheila graphs so next game most likely
well most likely Magnus will face Uralic
language or Maxime var Sheila Grove so
we can pretty much expect we'll be
covering that and as we've covered a lot
of Carlson's games today you know I will
be checking up in your hashtag
suggestions for what to show tomorrow
before the start of round 3
so I do hope you enjoyed it once again
I would like to thank salmon sir villa
now as your first saw Julian you subs
are they CB Jo and Vees and Trevor
Terrace for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Vita
world and rap world rapid and blitz
championship
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day